game one the entire second half so far
though the Lakers have taken 14 shots
Davis has only taken one but Thompson
has taken two and that's his first mate
turning gets into the corner so good
floating out of bounds that's good
defense good contest but he Klay
Thompson doesn't
[Applause]
he was only six of 20 from three so far
in the playoffs Thompson the soft touch
gets the bounce first one I mean this is
the second one just pushing transition
don't build the wall he sees nobody in
front of him at six seven that's a layup
for Klay Thompson
[Applause]
stolen by Curry
on the drive now pulls back finds Clay
Thompson his three-pointers
made a couple
absolutely outstanding unselfish plays
here probing in transition fundamentally
drops it off such a critical player for
these Warriors missed all those games at
the end of the season with a personal
Family Matter last 25 games is Johnson
hits a three
Anthony Davis just two points here in
the first half Wiggins a three
rebound Thompson on the tip from
Draymond Green playing exclusively one
big tonight
good tip by Green Johnson lobs it into
green
Thompson feeling it a bit right now
knocks down another three his fourth of
the first half
think about how great it's shooting this
is that one
even Kinto with the save Here Comes
Wiggins Thompson is open fires up a
three got it
[Applause]
Thompson Cuts back Reeves right on him
Reeves trying to fight over the screen
Thompson gets a little room and hits it
free
Thompson fakes fires punching in
[Music]
but you talked about a coach taking
advantage of that size posting him up
yeah if you're gonna have to chase a
smaller guy and again he had Curry on
him as Thompson hits another three all
night long aggressively looking to score
and shoot the back another tough shot
curling top of the key to kicks it back
out Reeves extra pass hachimura not that
time
pull ahead to Thompson Thompson on the
drive lays it up and in a 30-point game
for Klay Thompson this coming doesn't
matter yeah and then in transition
just an easy one but coming up a couple
rough